let's get into John Brown's question I'm
44 with a wife and three kids and I want
so badly to take a bold step into the
unknown what advice would you give me if
I cornered you at a coffee shop one
morning hey John I'm sympathetic to that
question although I have very few facts
to go on here in order to answer this I
think the first thing I would say is why
a bold step like what's going on in your
life right now where you feel compelled
to not just make a change but make a
bold change and I think you need to
answer that for yourself first right
like what is what's the discontent or
the the I don't know what would it call
what would you call it like the lack of
groundedness that the that gives you
that kind of anxiousness yes why intends
to status right yeah like oh yeah that's
what I see in that like why does it have
to be bold
so understanding that I think it's the
first step to trying to figure out what
to do next you have three kids you have
a wife you're 44 I don't know what your
occupation is I don't know what your
satisfaction with your occupation is I
don't know if this bold step that you
want to make is professional or personal
so that makes it challenging to answer
this but I think I would I would presume
you're meaning professional when you
have three kids and a wife I would
caution you from being too bold I think
that it's romantic
this idea of quitting your job and you
know sailing to Argentina with cans of
tuna right your boat or something like I
know but I'm just saying like if you're
feeling stuck like that you can
romanticize these other paths for
yourself without fully thinking them
through yeah so short of a bold step my
suggestion to you would be what can you
do right now that doesn't require you to
burn your life down to the ground right
like whether it's a side hustle or just
finding something that brings you
happiness that you can lend greater
expression to your daily life would be
the place to start
just because you're you have something
in your life that's not functioning
properly doesn't mean that you have to
cast aside everything else and and and
do something super drastic you know you
know there is a pragmatism to all of
this because those bold steps although
sexy have ramifications for the other
people in your life and of course you
have to think all of that through so the
advice that I would give you if you
cornered me in a coffee shop would first
be a bunch of questions I would need
answers in order to give you that advice
but I think it begins with being
intentional about how you're spending
your time on a daily basis and having
the mindfulness to carve out sections of
your day every single day that are just
for you or you can invest in that one
thing that one activity that one
practice that can bring you a little bit
more joy and also perhaps be a stepping
stone towards that bold step that you
can take at a later time
[Music]
you